yeah something else that's just been
announced is that Twitter is going to be
opening up
um trading through etoro for stocks and
crypto uh maybe also custody
basically Elon Musk is uh turning
Twitter into the Western WeChat
for those that don't know WeChat is an
application in um China kind of looks
like WhatsApp but you can pay and do
like most of what you want to do in your
life through WeChat it's also connected
to their social credit system
so so hold on a sec so Elon Musk is
turning Twitter into a crypto wallet
trading platform or is that just going
to be integrated into it
I have no idea what's a what is going to
look like I just know the news they
haven't announced the way that it's
going to look the point is that you'll
be able to uh hold Buy sell crypto and
stocks as well as uh transfer to other
people like if I want to send you some
cash then I can do it through Twitter
um so I I could maybe speak on this a
little bit from what I've heard so um
then again this is just off the top of
my head yeah I think that so Elon Musk
what he's done is I think that he's
trying to fold Twitter into
um x x.com a compare company called X
and it'll be a substitute
um
um Twitter will be a subsidiary along
with Tesla and SpaceX and um I think the
boring company and his brain um The
Brain Company so I think they're all
like I think it's called or something
they're all like yeah so those will be a
subsidiaryfx.com and so now what he
wants to do with Twitter is that there
is an app called WeChat in uh China and
it's pretty much the everything app so
you can pay your bills you can text
people you can do communicate
um all the stuff through this ad app
called WeChat and it functions similar
to Twitter in in China and you know Elon
Musk he has
um experience in that space obviously
with PayPal
right and so um you know every time I go
to the United States I'm surprised at
how hard it is to send somebody cash
um it's much easier in places that have
like in Canada we have the interact
Network I can just email money transfer
somebody up to three up to three grand
whereas it's way harder to do that in
the states so there is the opportunity
there for him to kind of make Twitter
into the everything app
yeah there was also a announcement he
made last week as well too in this
timeline
um where monetization is going to be
enabled and broadened and they're going
to let creators keep 100 of the
monetization I think for the next year
if I understood it correctly
um for things like longer form video
content and
um who's the other one that you were
talking about
newsletters yeah yes yeah stuff like
that so that'll be good because I mean
Twitter is is right now the only large
mainstream Free Speech platform
everywhere else you get censored
um that'll be interesting I mean if you
can do like a full podcast on Twitter
and say whatever the [__] you want
however the [__] you want to say I mean
as long as you're not you know
collaborating invade another country or
something you know like absurd like that
obviously but
um that'll be great that'll be fantastic
man that'll you know that'll give us
another Rumble that'll give us another
platform that lets you sort of
chop up ideas that you want to chop up
in a free way where you're not going to
be throttled back so we'll see how that
goes too yeah you know it's kind of
funny how there was a spot that Elon had
with a guy maybe a month or two ago how
they were talking about the ad rates and
about how the people that run the ads
from Twitter are so incompetent in that
Instagram has Sky High ad rates Facebook
Google Twitter it was just the worst for
their ad algorithm
um there's a lot of potential there if
he can figure it out figure out a way to
monetize it well they're breaking even
now you know he made that announcement I
guess you know because of the um
verification badges they're now paid for
which I don't mind paying for I don't
give a [__] but um but I mean like
they're breaking even now so they're not
losing money anymore you know which is
yeah which is the start but I mean the
way that he runs businesses he's gonna
he's gonna be turned turning this thing
into a cash cow in the next few years
for sure yeah all these businesses like
we know when he started with with Tesla
like it was it was in in the hole you
know and it's like I think Jason
calcaneus lent him the money to for the
the initial Roadster if he wouldn't if
he wouldn't got that money they would
have been toast same thing with SpaceX
they were down to their last rocket and
then they were just like okay if this
doesn't work the company's done and it
worked they got the contract from NASA
and then so it's kind of been this way
with all the companies that he's kind of
taken over it's always been chaos at
first and then again everybody else is
gonna try to catch up with them like
Matt is introducing the paid uh Bluetick
and everybody else is going to try to to
catch up with uh with footer it makes
sense did you guys see if we sit down
interview he did with the BBC earlier
this week
yes that is a master class in how to
handle the media coming at you in bad
faith it was you lied yeah it's just
absolutely I can't see through through
that you can't see anything
I saw somewhere during the week and it
said when you when you see the word news
just say narrative instead because it
makes things a lot it takes it makes
things a lot easier it's all narrative
it's not really not reporting anything
it's just here's our narrative and we're
going to show you a couple of sound
bites to fit our narrative and a
confirmation bias and you'll go off them
but it's yeah I mean when we were
growing up it was like the news was the
news it was some old dude came on at six
o'clock and generally read out what
happened without any spin nowadays
everything is spin yeah
you know it's funny just because out of
all the people
um at least people need to know that the
media are not your friends like they
don't they don't give a [__] about you
they just want that godship moment
government too man yeah and they can
point and say hi look I got you Elon I
got you you know but this guy like Elon
he knows like in 2021 Elon was the times
person of the year and he went from that
in one year to being like to not see
your right wing you know just within one
year though right it's because it's just
like Elon bad Elon bad Elon bad okay
Elon bad now okay Elon bad Elon bad
immediately
wasn't here other times person of the
year in like 1939 and Stalin was times
person of the year at some point yeah
but it's just it's just illustrative of
how they how they you know this guy was
the hero of the environmental movement
for years and you know just because he
advocates for for free speech then you
know you've got liberals in California
selling their Tesla stock and selling
their cars because the guy dared let
everyone have an opinion and you know
but you can sorry
let me just go for a computer I think
it's because he took their baby though
right that Twitter was it's all the blue
check marks on Twitter are mostly media
personalities and journalists and he
kind of took that away from them the
same way that like you know Trump took
away their baby their first female
president and no one never be able to
forgive him for that same thing with
this Elon Musk and Twitter he was
persona non grata they will never
forgive him for taking away your baby
used to silence people
Elon Musk and um what's his name Captain
Kirk
um what's that Canadian actor's name
Shatner Shatner William Shatner William
Shatner was publicly complaining on
Twitter about having to pay to maintain
his verification badge
dude you're loaded and you're
complaining about paying like 10 or 12
or whatever it happens to cost per month
to to maintain the verification status
because he's arguing well I've always
been verified why do I have to pay now
and like Elon Musk Chimes and he's like
everybody pays you know if you don't
like it basically go away it's quite
amazing that those who when when you
complain about raising taxes the small
increment there they'll tell you oh it's
only a tiny raise it's only like four
forty five dollars a month extra in your
property taxes those same people then
will complain about paying eight dollars
a month for verification yeah you you
can always cough up more taxes about
them they gank off of eight dollars a
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out